[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro de si on parlait sport spécial
Jeux Olympiques aujourd'hui ce jeudi 20
avril nous sommes au Vélodrome national
de 50 ans en Yvelines à l'occasion du
ski innovation et Talence est enceinte
sportive a accueillir les Jeux
olympiques dans moi de 500 jours au
cours de cette émission nous allons
évoquer différentes thématiques sur les
JO et il y aura un petit quiz à la fin
pour m'accompagner sur cette émission
Laurent mazory vice-président de 50 ans
en Yvelines délégué au sport et aux Jeux
Olympiques bonjour merci de m'accueillir
on est ravi de vous avoir sur ce plateau
il y a beaucoup de choses à dire sur CGO
ah bah on peut faire une émission de
deux ou trois heures minimum juste sur
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines et ça sera
avec grand plaisir qu'on répondra à
toutes vos questions bon là on sera à
peu près aux alentours de 40 minutes sur
cette émission mais bon
restez quand même nous avons également
avec nous à Nathan Bonatti alors chargé
de mission ESS 2024 une plateforme
solidaire qui a pour ambition de
favoriser l'accès des entreprises de
l'économie social et solidaire et des
entrepreneurs sociaux au marché liés à
l'organisation des Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques tout à fait c'est bien ça
je me suis pas trompé
pour les 40 minutes qui nous attendent
du coup et surtout pour le quiz
j'attends avec impatience du groupe on
l'attend tous avec impatience ce quiz et
on attend aussi avec un patient Arnaud
courtier Arnaud courtier qui est avec
nous conseiller spécial sur les Jeux
olympiques et paralympiques à 50 ans en
Yvelines bonjour
Michaela très bien on va parler sport
donc tout va bien bon 40 minutes on
s'est fixé 40 minutes
tout va bien parfait alors on va tout de
suite passer à notre première thématique
elle concerne la fameuse mascotte des
Jeux olympiques et paralympiques de 2024
je veux bien sûr parler des frises en
référence au bonnet phrygien vous les
avez peut-être vu dans les Yvelines
elles plaisent beaucoup aux enfants et
la fabrication se fait en Bretagne en ce
moment avec 500 unités produite par jour
au total 2 millions de friches devraient
être vendus avant et pendant l'événement
alors est-ce que vous êtes fan messieurs
nécessairement il faut pour des Jeux
Olympiques avoir de beaux symboles et
les symboles doivent être choisis avec
discernement et toucher les enfants et
toucher le plus grand nombre c'est ce
qui compte pour générer le sentiment
d'appartenance la passion donc moi je
suis assez fan c'est un côté un petit
peu dessin animé c'est évidemment très
français parce que c'est le bonnet
phrygien vous l'avez dit et puis la
bonne nouvelle c'est parce que pendant
un temps il y a eu un peu ce bruit qui
avait couru c'est qu'il est fabriqué et
qu'elles seront fabriquées en France en
Bretagne donc là aussi tout est symbole
parce que la Bretagne grand air évite
Grande Terre évidemment deux vélos et
comme nous sommes ici au Vélodrome
national de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
j'ai encore plus une pensée pour mes
amis bretons ça a du sens ah oui oui ça
a combien du sens mais la symbolique je
le redis elle est forte évidemment les
anneaux olympiques etc mais il y a les
mascottes pour tous les jeux hein c'est
les mascottes c'est hyper important il
faut que on s'y retrouve qu'elle
projette un esprit et je trouve que les
frises alors après tout est relatif
chacun peut y voir ce qu'il veut mais
moi j'ai trop fort sympathique et très
adapté on a nous-mêmes à 50 ans en
Yvelines avec Arnaud je sors très
souvent notre petite mascotte grandeur
nature je suis désolé elle est pas là
aujourd'hui et donc justement joski
en ce moment ah bah très bien alors on a
notre ami joski qui est pas une friche
mais qui est qui est un élan voilà et
nous on aime beaucoup avec Arnaud quand
on est en cours donc ça tombe très très
bien j'avais dit que la place Réunion
c'est là donc j'ai dit point donc oui
bien joué c'est très important et puis
toucher les enfants c'est déjà touché
les parents et puis c'est s'assurer
aussi de la passion du sport dans le
futur puisque un des objectifs que nous
poursuivons avec les la queue des Jeux
Olympiques c'est d'amener un maximum des
habitants de 50 ans Yvelines et des
français voire des habitants du monde à
pratiquer le sport au quotidien au delà
des grandes prestations que font nos
champions et que feront les champions du
territoire donc et bien les mascottes
vont évidemment efficacement nous y
aider Arnaud est-ce que vous avez une
friche sur votre bureau en tant que
conseiller spécial sur les Jeux
Olympiques
pas encore mais ça devrait pas tarder
mais je veux en avoir une absolument
enfin les deux olympique et par
olympique elles sont très réussis je
trouve aussi il y a toujours quelque
chose de subjectif mais honnêtement
elles sont sympas tous les grands
rendez-vous sportifs internationaux ont
leur mascotte c'est loin d'être toujours
réussi
là honnêtement moi j'ai trouvé ça génial
ça parle à tout le monde ça a du succès
ça a fait parler certes mais au moins ça
existe c'est un marqueur de l'événement
aussi c'est un marqueur personnalisé
avec avec le logo des Jeux et je trouve
que jusqu'à maintenant la com de Paris
2024 sur ces sujets là et vraiment très
pertinente pour la Coupe du monde
1998 il y avait par exemple footix
mais on s'en souvient un petit mot sur
husky aussi
l'élan l'élan olympique ben voilà c'est
notre jet ski tout le monde l'aime bien
parce qu'il est sympa il est tout doux
il est présent sur tous les événements
il pleut aux enfants il pleut au grand
et il existe depuis maintenant plusieurs
années on est parti de loin mais voilà
il représente l'image du territoire nos
athlètes internationaux quand ils
partent sur des compétitions à
l'étranger de l'emmène avec eux avec la
version peluche et le way il a un vrai
succès mais il fonctionne très très bien
donc on est ravi d'avoir le ski Nathan
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez du coup de
cette
Laurent et Arnaud bien sûr voilà
mascotte est toujours quelque chose qui
reste vraiment si on regarde les les 10
dernières masques et des classements qui
sont sortis je pense qu'on se classe
très bien vraiment pour le coup la Free
j'ai assez bien réussi et c'est vrai que
voilà moi qui suis beaucoup sur les
enjeux de retombées économique local
ça partait on a eu un petit début de
scandale et j'aurais tendance à dire que
Paris 24 est très bien retombé sur ses
pattes en réussissant à relocaliser la
majeure partie de la production de ces
mascotte du coup et c'est un bel exemple
une belle histoire de structuration
filière locale du coup donc voilà pour
le moment la mascotte rien à dire alors
on va maintenant passer à notre deuxième
thématique elle concerne les entreprises
du territoire on sait les Jeux
Olympiques seront un vrai boost
économique pour les Yvelines même si on
sait les JO vont coûter plus de 4,4
milliards avec un budget provenant à 96%
du privé mais il devrait rapporter plus
de 10 milliards euros sur les prochaines
années est-ce que c'est un vrai boost
économique pour le territoire de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines et même des
Yvelines globalement Laurent Majorie
pour poser la question c'est déjà y
répondre oui c'est un boost économique
mais pas que mais pour les entreprises
du territoire et les entreprises de
l'Île-de-France et 77 % des entreprises
îles de France pas pardon 77 % des
acteurs qui interviennent sur les JO
sont des entreprises franciliennes donc
on voit déjà l'impact tout de suite
maintenant mais après ça s'estime aussi
dans le temps c'est à dire qu'accueil
aux Jeux Olympiques c'est pas que la
phase de préparation la phase de
livraison des ouvrages et la phase de
jeu c'est aussi la phase d'héritage avec
tous les bénéfices quand ils ont la
population et donc tous les événements
d'attraction pour y faire venir des
habitants qui par conséquent je sais que
le mot n'est plus à la mode sont des
consommateurs aussi et qui vont donc
avoir d'une manière d'une autre à faire
appel aux entreprises du territoire de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines et puis c'est
l'image du territoire pour les 100 ans à
venir la dernière fois qu'on avait les
JO on en parler Carnot hier c'était il y
a 100 ans donc tous les deux on était
pas là à l'époque je crois pas je crains
qu'on ne soit pas là pour les prochains
non plus même si à 50 ans on travaille
beaucoup sur la santé peut-être que on
pourra vivre jusqu'au prochain Jeux
olympiques mais j'en suis sûr mais en
tout cas pendant les 100 prochaines
années qui viennent les impacts pour les
entreprises du territoire grâce à
l'image acquise à la fréquentation
renforcée du territoire seront majeurs
on prend l'exemple de la Ryder Cup qu'on
a accueilli en 2000 il y a quelques
temps maintenant 2018 cette rider Cup
elle a eu la même chose elle a eu des
éléments positifs pour les entreprises
tout de suite mais ces éléments et ces
victoires continuent encore aujourd'hui
on vient au Golf National parce que
c'était un golf qui accueilli la Ryder
Cup donc on consomme local on achète
local on dort le calme on vit locale on
se promène on va visiter et de fait on a
forcément un phénomène de ruissellement
très positif pour les entreprises du
territoire et très intéressant toutes
les entreprises du territoire
c'est-à-dire les plus grosses mais
évidemment nos commerçants locaux nos
restaurants locaux on a une anecdote
mais je serais peut-être Arnaud la
raconter une autre consentait laveries
par exemple dont tu peux peut-être nous
parler je veux pas prendre votre place
[Musique]
qui nous disait récemment qu'il était
très content quand on faisait des
événements comme les championnats du
monde de ce film sur piste et donc on
s'étonnait mais pourquoi parce que
toutes les équipes étrangères sont là il
y a plus de 50 pays ils dorment dans les
hôtels et en fait ils ont besoin de
laver le linge tout simplement et ils
vont danser laverie et il me dit et moi
pendant la semaine de l'événement est un
peu avant et un peu après ça tourne
comme jamais voilà donc on avait pas
pensé à ça mais donc il y a un vrai
ruissellement oui un ruissellement à
tous les niveaux Laurent l'a dit c'est
il y a de l'immédiat il y a du cours du
Moyen et du long terme c'est ça qui est
merveilleux pour toutes les entreprises
parce que il y a l'aspect touristique
dans l'héritage mais les entreprises
travaillent pour les Jeux Olympiques des
entreprises de service à l'état de
niveau sur les Jeux Olympiques on a tout
tout les promoteurs de France qui qui
fabriquent le village olympique etc on a
des entreprises spécialisées à implanter
à 50 ans en Yvelines qui sont pas connus
du grand public mais aujourd'hui quand
vous voyez à la télé un match au Stade
de France ou à Roland-Garros vous avez
les fameuses cablecam au dessus qui
filme c'est une entreprise implantée à
Co il faisait motion qui a développé ça
qui a une qui fait qui est la seule dans
le monde à faire ça donc on a des
savoir-faire qui sont ceux d'entreprises
locales et qui à l'occasion ces grands
événements bien sur travail mais il faut
une démonstration de leur savoir-faire
qui vendent après sur d'autres
événements dont d'autres pays et dans
d'autres sites et donc ça fonctionne
Nathan qu'est-ce que vous en pensez
alors vous particulièrement vous
travaillez sur les Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques exactement et vraiment
factuellement du côté de SS 2024 nous
aujourd'hui on est en mesure de dire
qu'il y a 53 prestations qui ont été
réalisées par 34 entreprises du
territoire de 51 en Yvelines dans le
cadre des Jeux donc ça c'est pour tout
ce qui concerne les opportunités
directes les marchés directs de Paris 94
et après il y a encore une fois voilà ça
va continuer à rucher comme comme le
disait comme le disait Laurent moi j'ai
eu l'exemple il y a pas longtemps on
donne des formations du coup SS 2024
dans le cadre d'un programme qui
s'appelle la fabrique des jeux sur
l'accès à la commande publique alors on
parle très peu au final des jeux dans
ces formations par la banque commande
publique en général et ça s'inscrit un
petit peu dans l'héritage immatériel des
jeux voilà réussir à faire en sorte que
les TPE PME les plus petits accèdent
aussi plus facilement à la commande
publique
mais qui va générer le plus de de de
sentiment de se reconnaître à travers le
champion et d'équipe d'équilibre
d'égalité tous uniques etc quand vous
êtes une entreprise participer à une
oeuvre comme celle-là on est vraiment
dans le RSE moderne c'est vraiment ce
que l'on va chercher je prenais des
exemples très indirects d'ailleurs de ce
sentiment d'appartenance et je vais
citer une entreprise du territoire qui
s'appelle Jean-Claude Decaux Jean-Claude
Decaux va me dire bah ils sont déjà
installés existe oui mais la publicité
qui va arriver à ce moment à ce
territoire va se positionner sur ses
mobiliers et Jean-Claude Decaux emploie
qui il emploie un certain nombre de gens
avec des formations de différents
niveaux c'est le sujet d'ici de la plus
simple à la plus compliquée ce sont des
emplois non délocalisables il faut
entretenir réparer les mobiliers sur les
sites et cet argent qui rentre il va au
bénéfice de qui ont été 66% de ce qui
est perçu et reversé aux collectivités
territoriales dans l'intérêt en fait
général des habitants on va avoir nous
des moyens de communication
supplémentaires on pourra avoir des
investissements supplémentaires on va
pouvoir porter la parole de territoire
et donc toutes ces prestations là elles
sont justement dû évidemment Jeux
Olympiques et elle génère au sein d'une
entreprise comme Jean-Claude Decaux un
fort sentiment d'appartenance et
d'engouement pour les jeux je prends cet
exemple mais on pourrait le multiplier
l'exemple de la laverie qui est frappant
mais quand on prend la restauration s'en
est un autre quand on prend ce qui
touche même parce que on parle des jeux
mais il y a tout ce qu'il y a entre dans
les cheminements j'arrive à la gare je
vais sur le site des jeux qu'est-ce qui
se passe entre la gare et les jeux tout
ça Saint-Quentin va l'assurer avec
Île-de-France mobilité mais va l'assurer
dans les détails il faut des sanitaires
il faut du pariage il faut de la
signalétique quand vous êtes dans une de
ces entreprises là le sentiment de
produire ces éléments là pour les Jeux
Olympiques franchement c'est un sacré
sentiment de fierté donc vous y croyez
10 milliards d'euros plus de 10
milliards d'euros générés sur ces Jeux
Olympiques à moi je vous envoie plus
pendant l'événement et après bien sûr
alors voilà la vérité elle est là elle
est que on a tendance à assez bien et
encore mais assez bien calibré les
retombées directes mais nous on le voit
sur la Ryder ce qui est très intéressant
ce sont toutes les retombées indirectes
dans le temps mais dans des éléments y
compris matériels les territoires
aujourd'hui sont tous en concurrence les
par rapport aux autres c'est bien
naturel qu'est-ce qui va faire que vous
allez attirer une entreprise sur un
territoire par rapport à un autre alors
évidemment les transports évidemment le
logement j'allais dire les fondamentaux
il faut qu'il soit respecté bien entendu
mais après le petit clic le petit déclic
supplémentaire l'environnement sportif
l'image du territoire un peu aussi la
culture faut pas le faut pas le mettre
de côté bah tout ça les Jeux Olympiques
c'est le plus gros moteur de la partie
sportive et du fait de se dire si ils
savent accueillir des événements ils
seront en faire d'autres mais moi mon
sport au quotidien en tant que salarié
de l'entreprise en tant qu'habitant je
pourrais également le pratiquer
conclusion quand je dois choisir entre
je vais pas citer d'autres
agglomérations exprès et 50 en Yvelines
j'aurais plutôt tendance à choisir 50 en
Yvelines parce qu'il y a beaucoup
d'événements qui se passent dans les
Jeux Olympiques au delà peut-être des
chiffres économiques il y a aussi un
bien-être au sein des entreprises qui
vont bosser sur ces Jeux olympiques de
2024 Jeux olympiques et paralympiques de
2024 vous y croyez Arnaud il y a un peu
une émulation aussi au sein des
entreprises oui oui j'y crois on
travaille sur un événement comme l'a dit
Laurent mazouri sera peut-être une seule
fois dans une vie il y a ça et puis il y
a une prise de conscience on est dans
une époque où on alors on sait que le
sport c'est plutôt bon pour la santé
si on en fait pas c'est pas bien si on
en fait intensément ça risque d'être
dangereux aussi mais si on en fait
normalement c'est bon les gens aiment
sortir et on a connu des périodes
compliquées le covid etc il y a une
certaine prise de conscience et
aujourd'hui les entreprises elles
prennent conscience du fait que si elle
s'accompagne leurs salariés dans leur
pratique sportive
ça leur revient positivement en fin de
compte si je suis bien dans ma tête bien
dans mon corps je suis plus à l'aise
pour travailler je vais être plus
productif et je vais être heureux au
boulot c'est assez simple mais en fait
ça marche et on a la chance en plus à 50
ans d'avoir des entreprises nombreuses
dynamiques dont certaines sont des
partenaires officiels des jeux je pense
à Egis je pense à Alltricks qui est
filiale de Decathlon je pense à Atos etc
donc ils sont impliqués dans cet
événement donc ils ont envie eux aussi
que ça ruisselle en interne et que les
salariés se sentent concernés et donc
les inciter à la pratique sportive les
accompagner dans cette pratique sportive
et pas uniquement en donnant pour une
inscription dans un club en organisant
des événements en faisant dire des
coachs en s'inscrivant à des courses
ensemble il y a plein de manières de le
faire mais on est tous conscients
aujourd'hui que le sport est évidemment
un enjeu de santé très très important
pour tous les âges et toutes les
générations et que l'entreprise a un
énorme pouvoir à ce niveau-là pour
accompagner ces salariés dans le cadre
de leur bien-être maintenant vous y
croyez vous aussi bien sûr bien sûr bien
sûr on le voit enfin on le voit on le
voit bien au quotidien et c'est des
choses qu'on qu'on il y a une vraie
prise de conscience là-dessus et j'ai
retenu à dire que les choses évoluent du
bon côté je sais que voilà le
aujourd'hui le l'État va expérimenter de
mettre en place deux heures de sport en
plus dans les dans les semaines des
collégiens et je trouve que c'est une
très bonne chose et j'espère que ça va
continuer on passe maintenant notre
troisième thématique à un gong qui vient
de retentir ici au bon endroit national
de saint-quentin-en-y c'était pas prévu
mais apparemment le timing est bon le
timing est bon alors on passe maintenant
notre troisième thématique elle concerne
évidemment toujours les Jeux olympiques
et paralympiques de 2024 l'événement va
être suivi par des milliards de
téléspectateurs mais ce n'est pas le
premier événement international organisé
ces dernières années sur le territoire
de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines il y a eu
en 2018 une certaine Ryder Cup
l'équivalent de la Coupe du monde du
golf au golfe nationale de 50 ans Libye
la question sur cette thématique les
Jeux Olympiques sont-ils un événement
encore plus grand que la Ryder Cup alors
je sais Carlo vous êtes un fan de golf
donc
la question peut être un peu compliquée
non en fait elle l'est pas honnêtement
je préférerais pouvoir vous dire que la
rigueur
mais ce serait un mensonge les chiffres
parlent d'eux-mêmes il y a une réalité
il y a un classement on se dispute la
deuxième la troisième la quatrième place
sur les grands événements sportifs
internationaux mais incontestablement
les Jeux olympiques sont ce qu'il y a de
plus grand c'est plus de 4 milliards de
téléspectateurs c'est véritablement le
seul événement qui est totalement
planétaire qu'on soit sportif ou pas
d'ailleurs ça marche partout on attend
je crois entre 15 et 17 millions de de
touristes à Paris
tous les sports sont là c'est voilà
c'est que ça le nombre de sites etc la
Ryder Cup c'était énorme mais c'est un
sport un site une semaine alors oui
c'est diffusé dans le monde entier oui
c'est un succès médiatique énorme parce
que le golf et le sport individuel le
plus pratiqué dans le monde rappelons-le
mais à la aux Jeux Olympiques il y a
tous les sports il y a le golf et il y a
les autres donc forcément tous les
spectateurs tous les téléspectateurs à
un moment ou un autre se sentent
concernés et puis ça fait partie de ces
rendez-vous même si on n'est pas un
aficionados de sport qu'on en regarde
pas beaucoup à la télé d'habitude quand
il y a les Jeux Olympiques on se
retrouve toujours à un moment donné dans
son écran à regarder une finale 200 m de
tennis
et un petit français qui d'un coup on se
rend compte que dans le tir au pistolet
à blanc à 50 mètres on a un gars qui est
en lice pour la médaille d'or du coup on
le connaissait pas la veille mais c'est
pas grave on supporte à fond donc voilà
ça crée ça les Jeux Olympiques c'est ça
qui est magique donc c'est une espèce de
moment de de communion d'union sacrée et
au-delà même de ce qui se passe en terme
de valeur c'est quand même quelque chose
d'assez intéressant Laurent
vous aussi vous êtes un fan de golf moi
aussi le problème du golf qu'il est il
est plus connu à l'étranger enfin plus
pratique à l'étranger qu'en France c'est
c'est bien le défaut mais là pour le
coup les Jeux Olympiques c'est c'est
quand même très très français aussi je
retrouve un petit peu un petit peu ce
qu'on a avec le dans ces grands rêves
dans ses grands rendez-vous c'est la
récurrence du Tour de France qui partira
ici le 23 juillet du vélodrome de nation
de 50 ans en Yvelines de cette année
c'est comédie Arnaud à un moment donné
on allume sa télévision parfois on
comprend rien alors moi je vais prendre
le vélo parce que je trouve que le vélo
c'est l'exemple type le vélo sur piste
il y a sur piste voilà
30 catégories voilà on regarde parfois
les vélos on comprend pas qui est devant
qui est derrière mais enfin passe un
super moment et puis quelques minutes
avant la fin la cloche effectivement du
dernier tour authentique et on est là
avec son drapeau français si un Français
Advent donc il y a pas plus
tu motivant plus passionnant que de
regarder une compétition de de jeux
olympiques si on prend l'aviron d'un
point de vue télévisuel c'est compliqué
c'est compliqué à suivre et pourtant on
sait qu'en France on brille c'est
bâtonnier story le contraire mais on va
le regarder et effectivement on aura
oublié le nom de l'oeil du champion de
la championne après et je prends un
exemple quand même également qui est
très fort dans le cadre de des derniers
Jeux Olympiques c'est le succès du
paralympisme parce que quand on regarde
les temps de sur France 2 désolé de
citer un concurrent à tv78 mais il nous
arrive pas à la cheville rassurez-vous
il essaie d'y arriver sur France 2 On a
vu le taux d'audience motivé par 8 sur
le paralympisme c'était du jamais vu
avec des athlètes qu'on ne connaît pas
encore moins que les valides j'allais
dire avec des performances incroyables
et je trouve que c'est la première fois
comme on a eu un peu le cas aussi sur le
championnat du monde au niveau de la
Coupe du Monde pardon de football
féminine qui a été également très suivi
je pense que cette mise en perspective
grâce aux Jeux olympiques de sport
inconnus motif des gens ensuite à
regarder du sport y compris du sport
plus compliqué apporter à la télévision
traditionnellement et ça pour nous
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines ça nous va
bien parce qu'on a des sports qui sont à
la fois vert quelque part écologique
puisque qu'est-ce qui a plus écologique
qu'un vélo et bizarrement qu'est-ce
qu'il y a plus écologique que le golf
aussi vu entre autres les efforts qui
sont faits sur la façon dont on traite
les terrains et qui ont donné lieu à
partir des terrains à des applications
qu'on a fait dans la vie de tous les
jours sur l'entretien et la maintenance
des espaces verts dans les collectivités
donc on voit l'efforts qui a été fait
par le golf mais pourtant ce sont des
sports qui sont dans des petites
fenêtres pourtant ils sont pigment
emblématiques et à la finale il passe
très bien à la télévision regardez par
exemple faites-vous attraper si vous le
pouvez par une fois par une
retransmission de golf sur je vais bon
alors je vais pas citer d'autres chaînes
mais il y a un plus derrière et
retransmettre du golf vous connaissez
rien en colle vous zappez dessus mais
vous êtes en train de voyager en fait
quand vous regardez la compétition de
golf même un quart d'heure mais je vais
aller dans ce pays je vais devoir cette
destination je vais dans cette région de
France et cet aspect y compris motivant
du sport pour le tourisme de voyage ça
nous semble très très important et c'est
le succès de ces retransmissions
télévisées de ces grands événements et
je précise qu'on couvrira évidemment les
Jeux olympiques de 2024 sur TV 78 on a
eu deux accréditations je tiens
normalement je serai un peu privilégié
ça va se battre pour la deuxième place à
mon avis mais bon la première
normalement ça devrait être moi Nathan
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez vous rider
Cup en dessous des Jeux Olympiques je
suis pas un aussi grand fan de golf que
Laurent et Arnaud du coup j'aurais du
mal à juger sur la question
que voilà enfin l'organisation de la
Ryder Cup la la très bonne organisation
la réussite de l'organisation de la
Ryder Cup à montre des mondes que voilà
les Yvelines sont tout à fait capables
d'organiser ce type d'événement majeur
et permet aujourd'hui bah de de préparer
très sereinement l'accueil de ces
épreuves des Jeux Olympiques que ce soit
le golf que ce soit les épreuves de
cyclisme et et toutes les autres qu'on
pourra voir sur le territoire Yvelines
yvelinois et partons en France Arnaud en
2018 on a eu Tiger Woods réussi à 50 ans
en Yvelines Rory McIlroy l'un des plus
grands champions de golf du moment
là il y aura aussi des stars en 2024
dans leur domaine et dans leur sport
respectifs dans certaines dans certains
sports dans certaines compétitions il y
a des stars connus du grand public et
peut-être d'ailleurs que le Roy est
Tiger Wood pourrait peut-être être
présent encore une nouvelle fois à
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines Tiger Woods ça
risque d'être un peu plus compliqué mais
côté Royaume-Uni on sait pas encore mais
en tout cas on espère qu'ils seront là
parce que
les jeux ont démontré leur attractivité
le golf est revenu aux Jeux Olympiques
le premier donc champion olympique de
l'histoire golf moderne c'est Justin
rose là la compétition aura lieu au golf
national c'est extraordinaire sur un
parcours où c'est jouer la Ryder copy le
connaissent les grands joueurs mondiaux
donc je pense qu'ils auront à coeur de
venir essayer de gagner cette médaille
olympique donc oui il y aura des grands
champions je voudrais juste revenir sur
quelque chose qui a dit Laurent qui est
très on a parlé paralympique et profiter
d'être à l'antenne parce qu'on il y a
une question qu'on nous pose beaucoup et
de plus en plus c'est mais pourquoi on
fait pas les Jeux paralympiques en même
temps que les Jeux Olympiques avec une
cette question elle est teintée d'une
envie de me montrer le paralympisme et
il est important de dire que au-delà de
raison
organisationnel et logistique les
athlètes paralympiques ne veulent
surtout pas être en même temps que les
Jeux Olympiques parce qu'ils veulent
leurs fenêtres d'exposition et qu'ils
ont bien raison si c'était entre
guillemets noyé dans la masse on les
verrait moins alors qu'on voit bien
justement Laurence que tu disais que les
Jeux paralympiques sont de plus en plus
exposés de plus en plus vues de mieux en
mieux vu et ça c'est très important pour
tous ces athlètes qui sont vraiment
admirables Laurent il y aura des stars
ici dans ce vélo de national de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines on pense
notamment à Mathilde de gros par exemple
notre pistard de française
mais il y aura toutes les stars d'abord
parce que c'est une discipline dans
lequel on brille on s'est fixé deux
objectifs alors ça c'est avec Arnaud et
moi c'est de battre à la fois nos amis
anglais et nos amis hollandais par
contre on les accueillera avec plaisir
dans la Fan Zone pardon dans le village
olympique de 50 ans en Yvelines on sera
heureux des accueillir pour offrir une
bière pour sécher leur larmes donc oui
il y aura toutes les stars mais ce
vélodrome les a déjà accueillis à
plusieurs reprises avec deux
championnats du monde avec Lucie track
Champions League qui a lieu dorénavant
régulièrement il est fait pour ça il a
été conçu pour que la France brille
parce que c'est le seul le seul seul
outil qui nous reste de la candidature
de Paris 2012 qui a été réalisé et qui
accueille la Fédération française de
cyclisme mais qui accueille
l'entraînement et pendant qu'on parle on
les a vu tourner peut-être tout à
l'heure l'entraînement des équipes de
France aussi bien en individuel que que
en équipe deux cyclisme sur piste donc
les stars elles sont fabriquées ici
fabriqués mais c'est elle qui ont tout
le mérite de pédaler mais elles sont
créées ici on les encourage quand même
on les encourage ici elles ont
d'ailleurs animé le vélodrome y compris
pendant une période un peu plus triste
qui était celle où le vélodrome était
transformé en vaccinodrome avec pas
moins de 400 000 va situation qui ont
lieu ici et elles ont tourné pendant ce
temps là et si on a investi autant et
avec avec Arnaud on a mis facilement un
euro chacun donc on souhaite que cette
fois-ci on soit au rendez-vous on a eu
une petite déception au dernier Jeux
Olympiques donc j'espère que là on y
sera j'ai que la fédé à faire très très
gros travail pour que nos stars brillent
et qu'on ramène plein de médailles comme
on a déjà commencé à le faire et vous
avez raison de souligner pour les
derniers championnats du monde entre
autres sur la partie féminine ou la
moisson a été plutôt sympathique avec de
nouvelles athlètes qui ont été très
efficaces très agréables j'ai eu le
plaisir de le remettre des médailles et
franchement c'est des super filles et
pas que sur la piste c'est à dire qu'il
y a vraiment ce côté un esprit sain dans
un corps sain mais c'est dingue corporé
sado qu'on retrouve particulièrement
dans les sports que l'on a ici que ce
soit au golf on en a parlé mais le vélo
est très générateur de gens qui derrière
beaucoup d'autres sports mais ont déjà
pensé à la prêt parce que ce sont des
fenêtres professionnels très courtes qui
nécessitent au moment où donne les
premiers tours de de savoir déjà
ce que l'on va faire après alors qu'il y
a des sports qu'on peut pratiquer
beaucoup plus longtemps on va maintenant
passer à notre prochaine thématique nous
je le disais tout à l'heure nous sommes
à plus de 500 jours du début des Jeux
Olympiques on le voit un peu partout en
Île-de-France il y a des travaux pour
accueillir dans les meilleures
conditions cette compétition
internationale reste donc légèrement
plus d'un an pour tout mettre en place
je crois qu'à Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
on n'est pas trop mal avec le vélodrome
national de 50 ans en Yvelines qui est
presque prêt ou encore le Golf National
de 50 ans en Yvelines le plus gros des
travaux c'est la colline d'Élancourt
évidemment quels sont les travaux
justement qui restent à faire sur
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines pour
accueillir cet événement international
Arnaud je vous donnerai ensuite la
parole en réalité des quelques travaux
oui d'aménagement pour des dispositifs
spécifiques on peut dire qu'on est bien
loti finalement à 50 ans en Yvelines on
est bien loti mais c'est le fruit d'un
travail depuis des années et des années
c'est le fruit d'accueil de grands
événements sportifs dans les années
précédentes de l'Open de France de la
rider Cup des champions du monde de
cyclim sur piste etc on en est pas à
notre coup d'essai il y a des travaux en
cours sur la colline d'Élancourt
puisqu'on aménage la piste olympique de
VTT et ça c'est génial parce que d'abord
ça va être un nouveau site Olymp mais
comme les autres un site qui sera ouvert
accessible à tous donc un site sur
lequel rouleront les meilleurs athlètes
du monde mais aussi monsieur et madame
tout le monde un site vert un site en
pleine nature
je pense pas me tromper en disant que
c'est le seul chantier des Jeux
Olympiques sur qu'on réalise son couler
un gramme de béton donc ça c'est plutôt
bien on en profite pour nettoyer la
colline
enlever des espèces invasives etc donc
en fait la régénérer pour que les
générations futures puissent en profiter
donc ça c'est super donc pas vraiment de
travaux lourds mais vous l'avez dit on
est à 500 jours des Jeux on va commencer
à rentrer dans le détail dans tout ce
qui a réglé et il y en a des choses à
régler parce que on l'a dit on attend
des des millions de spectateurs de
touristes il faut que la machine
fonctionne parfaitement un événement
comme celui-là il est il est colossal
mais voilà tous les détails doivent être
fonctionnels on y travaille les services
de Saint-Quentin ils travaillent en
relation avec le comité d'organisation
des jeux avec les services de l'État les
forces de police
Île-de-France mobilité etc une fois
encore les Jeux Olympiques c'est du
sport c'est du sport à quand il se
déroule en amont c'est tout sauf du
sport c'est de la logistique c'est du
transport c'est de l'aménagement c'est
des travaux c'est plein plein de choses
de la propreté urbaine donc voilà tout
le monde est mobilisé c'est extrêmement
motivant pour livrer un événement
parfait et il y aura des milliers de
spectateurs ici dans les Yvelines le
remasouri vous voulez rebondir là-dessus
est-ce que tout est quasiment prêt
tout est quasiment prêt donc comme
Arnaud l'a dit mais par contre on est
probablement le territoire qui est bon
le plus de chances de d'être prêt
peut-être même en avance même s'il y a
toujours des Kalash c'est un événement
un événement c'est la dernière minute il
manque un fil un câble un peu moquette
vraiment ça va jusqu'à ce genre de
détails d'anticiper et puis la partie
essentielle c'est effectivement la
partie postjo parce qu'en fait je dis
souvent c'est les JO c'est un peu de
sport mais c'est beaucoup beaucoup du
reste en fait beaucoup du reste c'est à
dire c'est essentiellement à la finale
de l'aménagement du territoire pour les
générations futures le vélodrome on l'a
dit tout le monde y tourne etc mais
demain la colline elle sera
effectivement ouverte pour tous les
niveaux de vététisme
surtout enfin c'est deux jours
d'épreuves ne VTT sur la colonel encore
c'est deux jours d'épreuve donc deux
jours d'épreuve on a travaillé dessus
pendant trois ans on a encore
pratiquement une année de travaux une
fois les JO réalisés puisqu'on va
réaliser les compensations écologiques
et finir d'aménager cette colline en
créant les différentes pistes des autres
niveaux mais également en l'ouvrant
ensuite à la totalité de la population
pour les promenades avec un vrai
challenge qui est de faire en sorte que
des vététistes puissent coexister avec
des promeneurs ce qui est loin d'être
toujours gagné entre autres quand on
pratique le VTT à la montagne on sait
que parfois ces sources de conflit le
pari qu'on a fait c'est d'avoir une
colline qui soit pensée en amont pour
accueillir les deux populations en même
temps et le côté poumon vert plus de 3
millions d'euros de compensation
écologique à la fois comme on l'a dit
Arnaud on supprime les invasives entre
autres de la célèbre renouée du Japon il
y a quoi qu'il a connait mais à chaque
fois que la plage j'ai une prime donc
j'ai placé la revue au Japon c'est là on
va l'éliminer et on va essayer
d'éliminer durablement et on va la
remplacer pour que les promeneurs
puissent reprendre leurs droits sur un
site qui sera dégagé de toutes les
pollutions qu'on pouvait avoir de tous
les erzas métalliques etc d'avoir donc à
la un gain pour la population au-delà du
sport ça c'est aussi et avant tout ce
que l'on veut faire des Jeux Olympiques
c'est éviter ces caricatures de certains
Jo on voyait des pistes abandonnés je
parle pas des Jeux olympiques d'hiver on
sait encore plus compliqué de recycler
mais où on a on se souvient les Jeux
Olympiques d'Athènes malheureusement
pour pas les citer on a eu beaucoup de
choses qui sont restés ensuite à
l'abandon c'est pas le lagageur de Paris
2024 et c'est pas l'engagement de 50 ans
au contraire c'est de faire en sorte que
ce soit au bénéfice des sportifs mais
aussi des noms sportifs et des
populations c'est comme ça que c'est
pensé il y aura un Test Event sur la
colline d'Élancourt absolument octobre
en septembre le
23 septembre 2023 c'est pas compliqué
c'est aujourd'hui je crois que ce
n'était pas encore officiel mais c'est
bien d'avoir une exclusivité
78 le festival tu auras lieu le 23
septembre 2023 c'est pas compliqué c'est
en même temps que que l'Open de France
de golf et c'est le jour également du de
des élections sénatoriales comme ça vous
pouvez il y aura du boulot certes par
contre vous pouvez tous venir au golf
national pour pour assister à l'Open
donc 23 21 juillet c'est Steven avec
5000 spectateurs environ 3 septembre
5000 spectateurs attendus dans la
version test pour une jauge
théoriquement suite à 12000 le jour des
événements on va le noter Nathan un de
travaux encore
voilà ça ça avance bien ça avance très
très bien même dans le cadre de 51
Yvelines et le contexte fait que voilà
voilà vu qu'il y a peu de choses à
construire que l'essentiel des
infrastructures est déjà là le travail
derrière est quand même beaucoup plus
beaucoup plus simple beaucoup plus
efficace et permet aussi de se poser
encore plus sur cette phase héritage et
de vraiment bien prendre le temps de
construire des projets qui s'inscrivent
dans la durée et qui vont vraiment
pouvoir servir derrière aux Yvelines
Linois voilà les Jeux Olympiques c'est
un événement gigantesque mais ça reste
deux semaines et derrière il faudra
encore une fois que que ça serve au
maximum et qui est le plus de de
d'effets positifs de l'accueil de ces
jeux ouais un an pour votre entreprise
c'est quand même assez court finalement
on a tendance à dire que c'est le sprint
là c'est l'année qui nous reste donc
effectivement tout accélérer enfin on le
voit bien le sujet jeu monte un petit
peu partout voilà moi ça fait un an du
coup que je développe la fabrique dans
les Yvelines aujourd'hui on commence à
être beaucoup sollicité et c'est normal
et on est très disponible encore une
fois pour du coup accompagner tous les
acteurs qui sont intéressés du coup par
ce saisir un petit peu du sujet pour
encore une fois que ce que ces jeux
soient une véritable réussite je le
disais tout à l'heure on va terminer par
un quiz sur les Jeux olympiques de Paris
2024 on va voir si vous êtes fort
messieurs si vous avez pas avec le
public ah le quiz peut être un peu avec
le public le public peut aider les
participants en tout cas alors on va
commencer par la première question qui
est le président du comité
d'organisation des Jeux olympiques de
Paris 2024 je suis question assez simple
on fait de Tony
Tony
est tombé Tony estanguay bon l'ancien
champion olympique de canoë
peut-être très gentil adorable très très
gentil effectivement oui oui il bosse
beaucoup apparemment en ce moment il
bosse beaucoup il est sur tous les
plateaux et il est partout je pense
qu'ils sont plusieurs à mon avis il y a
eu un clonage
alors question un peu plus compliquée
combien d'épreuves sont organisées dans
les Yvelines des preuves pas de sport
des preuves question beaucoup plus
compliquées
à Versailles bien sûr on rajoute le
passage du marathon le passage des
courses sur route
comme comme on est un brin communicant
78 78 c'est moitié moins 30 32 épreuves
sont organisées dans les Yvelines 32
épreuves quand même alors avant 2024
pour vérifier un mot parce que
on va vérifier normalement j'ai bien
compris
alors avant 2024 combien de fois la
France accueilli Jeux olympiques d'été
d'été attention une seule
fois une fois
une seule fois
si en fait en Gaule à l'époque deux fois
en 1900 et en 1924
Los Angeles en 2028 feront aussi bien
donc deux fois et troisième fois du coup
ce qui fait qu'en 2024
si vous avez les réponses alors quand
Paris a-t-elle été désigné ville haute
attention je vais dire en 2014 en 2014
[Musique]
on n'est pas loin 19
Laurent vous pouvez répondre jamais
parce qu'elle a été désigné en même
temps qu'une autre ville oui c'est vrai
donc du coup
bonne réponse en septembre 2017 avec Los
Angeles évidemment Jo 2024 quelle est la
date d'inauguration du vélo Drôme
national de 50 ans en ligne dans lequel
on est actuellement
c'est la dernière question précise si
possible la date précise en 2014
exactement
le 13 janvier 2014 et après il y a une
inauguration officielle à la fin du mois
voilà Nathan vous a pas trop entendu sur
sur le quiz vous l'aurez pas eu en fait
c'est un ensemble de questions pour
qu'on allait ridicules à la fin de
l'intérêt donc c'est assez réussi
en futur Jeux Olympiques
c'est comme ça bon je vais essayer de
m'accrocher quand même pour y être
déjà à la fin de cette émission va
terminer ceci on parlait sport spécial
Jeux Olympiques par une citation de
Pierre de Coubertin le père fondateur
des Jeux Olympiques modernes le plus
important au jeu olympiques n'est pas de
gagner mais de participer car
l'important dans la vie ce n'est point
le triomphe mais le combat ce n'est pas
d'avoir vaincu mais de s'être bien battu
je vous laisse méditer sur cette phrase
à bientôt sur TV 78
[Musique]